hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar broadcast hepatitis C
elimination starts with diagnosis this
webinar is part of the Abbott
Diagnostics webinar series innovations
in science to transform healthier
futures I'm Suzy Valdez and I am pleased
to be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by Abbott Abbott is
committed to helping you live your best
possible life through the power of
Health for more than 125 years they have
brought new products and technologies in
the world in nutrition Diagnostics
medical devices and branded generic
pharmaceuticals that create more
possibilities for people of all stages
of life today ninety four thousand
members of the Abbott team are working
to help people with not just longer but
better in the more of 150 countries they
serve for over 40 years
Abbott has been committed to delivering
the highest quality products to serve
our hepatitis in vitro diagnostics
community for more information please
visit them at wwe.com before we begin I
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of your presentation window
type that question into the box that
appears on the screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also notice
that you're going to be viewing the
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or use that Q&A
button and let us know you're having a
problem good news this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
educational credits click on the button
at the bottom left hand corner and
follow the process for obtaining your
credits without further ado I'd like to
now introduce today's speaker dr. Jean
Michelle pawlowski dr. Jean Michelle
Pulaski is a professor of medicine at
the
versity of Paris he earned his medical
degree in hepatology and
gastroenterology in 1992 as well as his
PhD in molecular virology from the
University of Paris France he is the
director of the national reference
center for viral hepatitis B C & D and
the department of biology and the
director of academic department viruses
immunity and cancers at the Henry
mont-dore University Hospital in Paris
France he focuses on teaching and
research in virology primarily hepatitis
viruses and liver oncology dr. Brodsky
is an active and numerous professional
societies and has been acting as the
secretary-general of a European
Association for the study of liver
between 2005 and 2009 dr. Pulaski has
been an associate editor of habit ology
an associate editor of gastroenterology
and is a member of Editorial Board of
the Journal of habit ology he is has a
noted career contributions including the
publication's of over 500 articles and
book chapters in his area of expertise
and over 500 invited lectures at
international meetings I'd like to now
turn the presentation over to our
speaker welcome dr. Polanski today we
will dis
all of the collaboratory in reaching the
World Health Organization HCB
elimination goals and we'll discuss how
we can improve access to care through
Diagnostics the slide shows my conflict
of interest disclosure and in the first
part of this presentation I would like
to discuss the WTO policy to eliminate
hepatitis C virus by 2030 hepatitis C
virus infection belongs to top 10
leading causes of mortality and it has
been ranked 10th and most important
cause of mortality in 1990 and went up
to the seventh cause of mortality in
2013 explaining that without active
intervention var hepatitis may continue
to move up as one of the leading causes
of death globally currently the
prevalence of HIV infection has been
estimated to approximately 71 million
people worldwide and HIV related death
occurs in approximately 700,000 to a
million people every year making HCV a
very important public health issue this
slide showed the worldwide prevalence of
HIV infection and as you can see here
the prevalence widely varies from one
country to another the prevalence is
relatedly low in Western Europe and
little bit higher in North America
between zero and point eight percent and
there are countries a very high
endemicity such as the Russian
Federation Eastern Europe Egypt and some
countries in Asia the size of the
circles indicates the total number of
infected patients in every area and
every country and importantly you can
see that the vast majority of patients
with HIV infection leave in lower to
middle-income income countries and upper
middle income countries forty seven and
twenty six percent respectively 19
percent in low-income countries and the
very small minority only 8 percent in
high-income countries where most
diagnostic and treatment tools
are available it's like now shows the
heterogeneous distribution of HCV
genotypes worldwide and as you can see
here to type one is by far the most
frequent genotype in every region it
represents in red more than
three-quarters of patients in North
America essentially subtype one a Geo
type one is also very frequent in Europe
where it represents a little bit more
than 50 60 percent of patients it is
also highly prevalent in Asia but other
genotypes are increasing to type 3 is
highly prevalent here in green in
Western Europe representing
approximately a quarter of patients and
very highly prevalent and dominant in
the Indian subcontinent whereas other
genotypes such as 2.4 are frequent in
Africa type 4 is also increasing
especially in the population of
intravenous drug users in Western Europe
and 2.5 is seen in South Africa has to
type 6 is frequently found in Southeast
Asia so a very heterogeneous
distribution of the different HIV
genotypes but overall HCV is present in
every continent and in every country for
these reasons and because of the very
high mortality rate associated with HIV
infection and the important morbidity
related to the infection the World
Health Organization has launched a
strategy to eliminate HCV by 2030 the
term elimination can be debated and we
should maybe rather speak about control
making a frequent disease or rare
disease but the goal has different
targets and these targets split into
prevention targets testing targets and
treatment targets the prevention targets
are the following the goal is that all
blood donations be screened by 2030
everywhere in the world this is far from
being the case right now and that 90% of
people have access to safe injections
the testing targets include 90 percent
of people
we are aware of their infection see the
vast majority of patients are unaware of
their infection in most countries in the
world and the treatment targets include
that 80 percent of HIV patients be
treated and 90 percent reduction in new
HIV cases is achieved if all of these
targets can be reached in the next 15
years then we will have it ignited or
more precisely controlled by appetite
ease is a public health issue by 2030
obviously this may look as like a
fantasy it's very difficult to achieve
but you will see in a moment that they
are tool that may help us to achieve
this very ambitious goal
currently the HIV diagnosis and
treatment rates are extremely
heterogeneous throughout the world and
especially throughout Europe this has
been well studied in Europe and you can
see here the it originate a of the
treatment rates shown in the x-axis and
the diagnosis rates shown in the y-axis
some countries have done pretty well as
you can see Francie's leading in terms
of treatment ray very close to germany
other countries have diagnosed very well
such as malta Finland Luxembourg that
are a bit late in terms of treatment and
some countries in Europe especially in
South Korea and Eastern Europe are
extremely late in their treatment and
diagnosis strategies and this includes
countries with very high rates of
infection and very large number of
patients who are still unaware of their
infection and do not have any access to
third so much progress remains to be
made and there are several challenges
and barriers to HP management that have
been identified so far some of these
barriers are related to the perception
of the disease with a low patient
awareness I mentioned before and the
issue of stigmatization of infection
that they prevent patients from being a
screen and diagnosed there are barriers
related to diagnosis when testing is not
freely available when access to testing
is limited
or when testing is available but
clicking linkage to care fails to bring
these patients to efficient care and to
be treated there are challenges related
to treatment itself is restricted access
to effective treatment in some areas and
the lack of infrastructures and human
resources in many low to middle-income
countries and make that even if the
infection is diagnosed the patient will
not have access to a good therapy in
their country finally there are issues
related surveillance and systematic
monitoring of the disease has not been
established everywhere and altogether
it's make that treatment and HP
management is remaining difficult
complicated in many countries how could
we improve these and the focus of the
second part of our presentation will be
on the role of biological tools in HIV
elimination and in trying to fight
against these different barriers and
challenges the first point and this is
probably the most important one is
screening screening of HIV infection
I've said before that the vast majority
of patients are unaware of their
infection which is very often a silent
infection it is important that these
people be screened for their infection
and that patients who carry the virus be
identified and then engaged into care
and treatment the World Health
Organization w-h-o as recently should
guidelines and these guidelines are very
precise in what should be done in all
settings the guidelines say it is
recommended that serological testing for
HIV antibody be offered with linkage to
prevention care and treatment services
to adults and adolescents from
populations most affected by HIV
infection these includes patients who
are part of a population with high HIV
prevalence and patient with a history of
exposure and/or high risk behaviors for
HIV infection and also in adults and
children with a clinical suspicion of
chronic pericarditis second point is
that in setting
where there is more than 2% or more than
5 percent HP intimates your prevalence
in the jail population it is recommended
that all adults have access to and we
offered HIV serological testing with the
King linkage to prevention care and
treatment services and finally birth
cohort testing may be applied to
specific identified cohorts of older
persons at higher risk of infection and
morbidity within population that have an
overall lower general feminine this is a
very detail and precise guidance for HCV
testing the WHL add that to test for
serological evidence of past or present
infection in adults and children above
18 months of age an HPV serological
assay antibody or antibody combined with
antigen using either rapid diagnostic or
laboratory base in the assay formats
that meets miller and safety quality and
performance standards with regard to
both analytical and finkle sensitivity
and specificity is recommended so two
different assays can be used and Eliza
assay centralized or locally a rapid
diagnostic test rdt finally our duties
are recommended in specific settings
settings where there is limited access
to laboratory infrastructure and testing
and/or in populations for access to
rapid testing with facilitates linkage
to care and treatment or have the use of
dried blood spots another type of assay
which I will show you in a minute the
use of dried blood spot specimens for
HIV antibody serology testing may be
considered in settings where there are
no facilities or expertise to take
venous blood specimens our duties are
not available
or they use is not feasible and their
person who is for venous access such as
patients or in drug treatment programs
prisoners etc this is what WHS says and
they have been other guidelines
published recently including the
guidelines from the infectious disease
Society of America and the American
Association for the study of liver
diseases which say that all persons
recommended for
we testing so first be tested for HIV
antibody antigen using an fda-approved
test this is for you the United States
and a be approved s include laboratory
based assays enzyme immunoassays and one
point of care I say they are a quick HIV
rapid antibody test which is currently
FDA approved in the United States
finally the European Association the
study of the liver ezel recommended the
following and this is very much in line
with in w-h-o guidelines screening for
HIV infection is presently based on the
detection of anti HIV antibodies rapid
diagnostic tests are deities using serum
plasma
fingerstick old blood or crevicular
fluid saliva as matrices can be used
instead of classical enzyme immunoassays
to facilitate anti to the antibody
screening and improve access to care and
all blood sample don dried blood spots
can be used as an alternative to serum
or plasma obtained by vinnie function
you can see here is three different
kinds of tests which I would like to
discuss now more into detail enzyme
immunoassays rapid diagnostic tests and
dried blood spots which all are
extremely helpful in the different
populations indicated by the WHI
guidelines for screening of HIV
infection first see Eliza test the
enlighted tests have many advantages
they are simple they are standardized
they are generally fully automated and
it's possible to have random access for
arjun diagnosis meaning that you can
stop the series you're performing to
include one sample that must be urgently
tested and they remain relatively cheap
not very cheap but relatedly cheap these
Eliza tests however have disadvantages
they require a central lab they require
equipment which is jelly extremely
expensive and big takes a lot of space
and they required trade trained
personnel and this is not always
possible everywhere in the world
so the rapid diagnostic tests are
different and I'm showing you here the
example of one of these tests and you
can see here that it is possible
load the blood sample or saliva sample
here on the test and then there will be
a migration of this blood upstream
through the nitrocellulose trip until
the blood sample or saliva sample meets
with antibodies or antigens in that case
it would be antigens
there will be an antibody antigen
reaction and this will be witnessed by
the appearance of a band and the
appearance of these bands indicate that
the anti HIV antibody is present in the
sample which again can be blood or
saliva it's a very simple principle very
easy to do and these rapid Diagnostics
office eventually general practitioners
the emergency room the intensive care
unit outpatient clinics rural areas and
even patients homes if necessary and
they can use original specimen
mattresses as alternative to old blood
serum or plasma for venipuncture and
this includes fingerstick or blood as
shown here in this slide and also oral
fluids as shown above and it's possible
to take saliva and detect anti HIV
antibodies is the Rd T's what is the
performance of h20 body Rd T you may
think that oddities are all equally good
this is not the case and I chose to show
you the results of this study that we
perform in my lab in 318 HD+ of patients
and 171 HIV negative patients and you
can see here that if the performance of
the first two essays was excellent with
a very good specificity sensitivity
positive and negative reiki value the
performance of the last one was really
really poor with a sensitivity of only
62.7% and a negative predictive value of
49.6% and this is just to emphasize the
fact that all
our duties are not equal they are not
all performing very well and it is very
important when you use an RDD that this
rdt has been tested before and that that
its specificity sensitivity plasti and
negative predictive values have been
correctly evaluated and confirmed to be
good so recently there was a publication
of a meta-analysis of Moda 13,000
individuals included in 18 studies
between 1994 and 2001 4259 specimens
were tested in cold blood from Venus and
capillary sampling and 13 994 specimens
were from saliva and as you can see in
this meta-analysis of appropriate rdt
the overall performance was very good
with specificity of 9.5 for all blood
and the 8.2 for saliva and a sensitivity
of 98.9 for all blood and 97.1 for
saliva so excellent performance and
interestingly there were in another
meta-analysis published for recently 30
studies more than 17,000 specimens there
was a comparison of the parameters that
could influence the performance of the
HIV our duties and importantly the year
of testing did not have any influence on
specificity or sensitivity the fluid
from which this was done did not
influence either the performance in
terms of sensitivity and specificity the
only parameter that had an influence was
the location and these assays performed
better in develop in industrialized
country that in developing countries
which could be problematic because it is
in developing countries that these tests
may be the most useful therefore it is
very important that the performance of
these our duties be validated not only
in heineken countries but also in
low-income countries middle-income
countries where these assays
we'll have all their value the other
possible way by which you can screen for
anti HIV antibodies is the use of dried
blood spots the principle of the dried
blood spot is very simple the first step
is fingerstick collection where you take
the patient's blood and load it onto the
paper then there is a barcode which
allows you to identify the patient and
to collect the blood sample and dried on
the paper directly the filter paper and
this blood sample on the filter paper
will be used in an automated sample
processing which is very similar to what
we do with plasma in a central lab so
this allows you to send the dried blood
spot to a central lab where analyzed it
is a very classical Eliza test will be
performed DBS are currently endorsed by
the World Health Organization and form
the backbone of HIV viral load and
resistant testing scallop efforts
globally so there is a lot of experience
on dried blood spots in the HIV field
and DBS are minimally invasive and are
very useful in some low income middle
income countries but also in
marginalized populations of
industrialized countries such as
injecting drug users men who have sex
with men sex workers etc etc they are
currently being implemented in many
settings to help screen and diagnose HCV
infection so what are the advantages and
disadvantages of DBS
their advantages are the low volume
required which is in the order of 50 to
70 microliters a good stability of the
biological metrics they are easy to
collect and to mail at room temperature
and different types of analysis can be
done including serological there are
some molecular mycological analysis all
of this can be done on media's the
disadvantages however are their lower
analytical sensitivity and the classical
biological matrices such
serum and plasma the fact that there are
no standardized procedures and the fact
that storage at minus 20 degree Celsius
may be required if the DBS are not
immediately analyzed and this may impair
the quality of the analysis the DBS are
not sent quickly and frozen within a few
days after being shifted to the central
lab this slide shows you the performance
of hte antibody detection by third
generation rises in samples from taken
from dried blood spots here it's a
finger stick blood sampling and as you
can see here population of HCV sir
negative patients a population of HCV
sir positive patients with resolved
infection and a population of HIV
positive patient with chronic infection
meaning that they are detectable HCV RNA
we had to reestablish the detection
cutoff for the anti HIV antibodies but
with the new cutoff established and
discrimination was excellent and it was
very easy as you can see here it's a
high sensitivity of 99.1 percent and a
high specificity of 98.2% to
discriminate among people who were HD
sir negative and people were HD sir
positives therefore it is very easy and
reliable to test for anti HIV antibodies
with blood or with blood taken from
dried blood spots the second point when
anti jeje antibodies have been detected
is to confirm the diagnosis of infection
and decide to treat or not to treat and
the decision to treat is made based on
the presence of HCV RNA and therefore a
tRNA testing is the standard of care to
confirm HIV diagnosis so far and this is
what is indicated in the WHI guidelines
which say that directly following a
reactive HIV antibody serological tests
result the use of quantitative or
qualitative nucleic acid testing for
detection of HCV RNA
recommended at the preferred strategy to
diagnose paramah confection powerful w
to add that an essay to detect hv core
p22 antigen which has comparable tinkle
sensitivity to nucleic acid testing is
an alternative to not to diagnose
dynamic infection
therefore the w technology that either
HTML testing or core antigen testing can
be used to confirm diagnosis and bring
patients to care and therapy ezel is of
the very same line and in its most
recent recommendations ezel indicates
that if anti HIV antibodies are detected
HCV RNA should be determined by a
sensitive molecule method HCV RNA
detection qualification should be made
by sensitive assay with a lower limit of
detection of less than 15 international
units per ml and if HCV RNA testing is
not available or not affordable HIV
quantity and detection qualification by
enzyme immunoassay can be used as a
surrogate marker of HIV replication
finally ezel adds that the HIV genotype
and genotype one subtype 1a or 1b must
be assessed prior to treatment
initiation and will determine the choice
of therapy among other parameters
finally IDs a and isld are on the same
line if the result of the anti HIV test
is positive current infection should be
confirmed my sensitivity on a test
qualitative etcheverry testing is
recommended prior to the initiation of
intimacy repeat to document the baseline
level of viremia
which is a based on viral load the core
antigen is not recommended by the ideas
and ice of the guidelines to do these
essays not using at the airport all year
and testing for HIV genotype is
recommended to guide selection of the
most appropriate and of our regimen
so let's now discuss a different essay
that are available and how they can be
used this slide summarizes of dynamic
countries of quantification of various
assayed are available in different
countries and as you can see these
essays cover very well
the low VAR loads on the left which are
seen on treatment in patients who
respond to therapy up to the very
high-value load that are seen before
therapy or in various mobility
conditions the gray area indicates where
95% of patients am that is 95% of
patients have their viral load here
which is comprised between five ten to
the four and five ten to the six
international needs per ml at the start
of therapy and you can see that the
assays cover very well the pretreatment
baseline downloads as well at the on
treatment downloads and the goal of
therapy which is a sustained on Jukka
response that corresponds to an
undetectable HCV RNA at 12 weeks after
the end of treatment
different assays have been developed as
I said most of them are centralized on
big machines automated machines in the
central lab there are not yet real
point-of-care tests we should probably
speak more about near care HCV RNA test
and there is one section here care test
which has been recently look develop and
I'm showing it here this is a very
simple system with a cassette which is
filled in by the blood sample the
cassette II could to the machine and the
machine after a few minutes we'll give
you the HCV RNA level with an excellent
correlation which you can see here on
the right between the HIV RNA level
measured in this assay and the HIV RNA
level measured in another reference sa
what about test
for HCV RNA from DBF I said before that
BBS can be used for molecular testing
and we assess the ability of samples
taken on DBS to be used for HIV testing
by comparing the HIV RNA level in serum
specimens on the x-axis is two different
assays with the HCV RNA level in all
blood specimens taken from VBS on the
y-axis and as you can see in both
instances there was an excellent
correlation between the two HCV RNA
levels from the same patient meaning
that VBS quantification of HIV RNA is
reliable
however the absolute number should not
be taken into consideration as the
absolute number in international units
per ml here in the DBS was shown to be
1.5 to 1.7 log lower that the absolute
number for the same sample if this
sample would tested directly from serum
or plasma so weak to detect a cheater
and then to say HD RNA is present but
the valid the number which is given with
the VBS is not as reliable as a number
that is given by directly the HDI now
saying when taken from serum or plasma
so what about the HBO antigen test I
said that this test is a surrogate
marker of HIV replication and it have
some advantages of her nap testing
reduce operational expenses stability at
room temperature for 96 hours short time
to resolve approximately 60 minutes
which is shorter than nap testing and no
need for NAT skills however these tests
must be performed in a central
laboratory on an automated device and
this may limit the use of these assay to
places that have access in such a
central lab destroy this slide
illustrate the fact that the core
antigen test is a surrogate marker on
HCV RNA levels and you can see here in a
study with recently published a very
good correlation between the age
level on the x-axis and the HTV core
antigen level on the y-axis the
analytical sensitivity of the quan chi
gene test is slightly lower than the
analytical sensitivity of the HEV RNA si
is a lower detection of the question si
which is equivalent to approximately 500
to 3000 HEV RNA international minutes
per ml and this varies according to the
HIV genotype and they have been rare
false negative results reported meaning
quarantine negative HIV and a positive
result so sometimes the quantity may
miss HEV the presence of HIV replication
that this is extremely rare and this has
been assessed in a recent systematic
review of HCV of corn to Gen versus HCV
RNA and you can see here the aura curve
that shows a good sensitivity and a good
specificity and overall a very good
predictive value of core antigen on the
presence of HCV RNA meaning that the
test can be used confidently to test for
HIV replication and this might shows you
the correspondence between the presence
of HCV RNA Emeco antigen and you can see
here that the two essays were concordant
in the vast majority of cases for the
one percent were positive in both assays
and 54 percent were negative in both
essay there were very few discrepancies
46 patients had a false positive of the
core antigen assay meaning approximately
point 57 percent and they were also rare
for negative results 3.5 percent but you
have to consider that in these series
they were patients were on treatment and
therefore this may reflect a lower
analytical sensitivity in the quantity
in essay as compared to the nucleic acid
testing essay so overall the year
conclusions of this systematic review or
that there is currently evident that
suggests that the HPV core antigen
detection performs as well as RNA based
assays for HCM
- man and that the user antigen test
could include access to HIV care in
under-resourced healthcare settings
which now remains to be validated we
also tested the ability of testing for
HIV antigen from dried blood spots and
here we were disappointed that this did
not perform well and this is due to the
lower analytical sensitivity of the corn
seed in Si it was as you can see here on
the left a good relationship between
core antigen assay and the HCV RNA level
but a large number of patients were
undetectable with a PO antigen is a very
big difference in the absolute value of
2.46 logs between core antigen in blood
taken from zero plasma and in blood
taken from DBS and this indicates that
the quantity n test is not sensitive
enough to be used from dreadlocked spots
and therefore should be limited to use
on serum and plasma the last point in
the recommendations from WOA SLD IDSA
and easel is the genotype and this slide
summarizes the different treatment
options as recommended by the recent
easel guidelines and this indicate that
even if we have many different record
regiments these treatment regimens
indicated here should be tailored to the
genotype and not all genotype have the
same treatment to type one here has
several options if you persevere
supportive years of alveolar plateau
severe because nearby that will be
written in here etc it has it's much
more limited to do type 203 which can be
treated only with the probability of F
atmosphere or suppose you hear the
clatters here a little bit more options
for G time for and slightly less option
for treat at faxes at least to say that
as soon as diagnosis it to confirm and
you decide to treat the patient it is
extremely important that you identify
the HCV genotype and also the subtype
treatment will be tailored with this
information they are different than say
it available for HB Judah being that the
most widely used essay and probably the
most accurate wine in the line table
assay in Odaiba and these are say is a
reversible ization based assay which
uses nitrous it'll strip onto each
different probes have been loaded and
these probes are used in the fight from
untranslated region but also in the core
region in order to discriminate well
among genotype one subtypes 1a and 1b
and also to discriminate 2 x 6 from to
attack one these assays which should be
very accurate and is widely used to
identify MGB genotype it's also possible
to identify the genotype in blood sample
on dried blood spots we've annotated
this and in a series of 263 patients we
found that there was a 100% accordance
at the dude that level subtyping was
known as easy as to type in subtyping
fell in 16 cases and was erroneous in
one case but overall the genotype 1 to 6
DB s can be confidently huge the third
potential step is HEV resistant testing
is it necessary to test for HIV
resistance prior to surgery the answer
is no this is what ezal recommends is
observe that systematic testing for HIV
resistance prior to treatment is not
recommended indeed this obligation would
seriously limit access to care and
treatment regimens to be optimized
without this information it is very
important and when we describe these or
guidelines we estimated that making an
obligation of recent testing would make
that the vast majority of physicians
worldwide will not have access i would
not treat patients knowing that it's
possible to optimize therapy and i will
show in a second it is not necessary to
do it however what is not recommended
is not forbidden and if some physicians
had easy access to a reliable test
assessing HD resistance to the NS 580
meters then they can use these results
to guide their decisions and these are
guidelines for by guidance for people
who do not have access to resist desk
and guidance for people and have access
to the resistant test what are the
reasons for not recommending HD hero2 in
testing they are listed on this slide
number one there is no standardized
essay that has been externally validated
for its performance and is easy to
written we use available as a
purchasable kit no essays no
standardized deputation reporting on
edge of your instance data no precise
definition of clinically relevant
resistance associated substitutions or
lessons and no clear-cut guidelines from
international societies to guide
treatment decisions altogether this make
that we could not recommend the use of
resistant testing in patients prior to
therapy and the guidance is the
following the guidance shows you that if
the resistant test is not available you
should optimize therapy to avoid
treatment failure and guidance is shown
the tricks are very simple if you think
the patient could have an influence on
the presence of resistance associated
substitutions you should add ribavirin
and prolong the duration of treatment or
prolong the duration of treatment and
there are different recipes to do that
with a different treatment regimens and
we're not going to be telling this on
the other hand if you have access to a
test which is available which is
reliable has been validated is easily
interpretable and it's understandable by
the clinician then the presence of an
extra virus's conferring higher level
resistance will indicate that only these
patients you have detectable instrument
lessons should a drug a valine and/or
increase treatment duration in those
patients the point is that this applies
to current treatment regimens but the
next generation of treatment regiments
will not need any adaptation based on
the presence
of many services and therefore this will
very soon become irrelevant the fourth
and final point is monitoring of
treatment efficacy one year sorry
treatment it is important to monitor
treatment efficacy and here ezal
recommends the use of a real-time PCR
assay with a lower limit of detection of
less than 15 international units per ml
to monitor htin levels during and after
therapy and easil also indicates that
like for the confirmation of diagnosis
measurement of HIV core antigen levels
by ia could be used as an alternative to
HCV RNA level measurement to monitor
treatment efficacy during and after
therapy when H again assays are not
available or not affordable but this
slide shows you the monitoring of
several patients in in a study we
recently published with two different
assays and you can see that if you use
two different assay the HCV RNA levels
are extremely close to each other and
this confirmed that HCV RNA test
currently are very well standardized and
it will allow you to monitor the respond
to therapy extremely accurately and this
other slide from another study we
perform now shows the relationship
between HCV RNA levels and in the x-axis
and HD quantity levels in the y-axis in
large number of patients included in a
clinical trial of new HCD joints and
these patients including those based on
download high-dollar loads and low bar
loads on treatment and as you can see as
you can see there was an excellent
correlation between the HCV RNA level
and the question level both at baseline
and on treatment and this early very
dates the use of kwanza gene testing to
monitor the response to therapy the
response is essentially monitored at 12
weeks post treatment is sustained
article response and this is something
that can now be done with the core
engine index so this
Prince bleep to my conclusion and the
conclusion is the following a number of
assays and tests now exist to diagnose
HIV infection and help clinicians to
make appropriate therapeutic decisions
novel assays are or will soon be
available and they will allow HIV
treaters to simplify diagnosis
assessment of severity treatment
decision and monitoring in order to
optimize access and linkage to care and
if we go back to this initial strategies
to eliminate HIV by 2030 you understand
well that biological tools cannot do
much on the prevention targets but they
can definitely improve the testing
targets the goal to have 90% of people
who are infected aware of their
infection by 2030 and also improve the
treatment targets make sure that 80% of
HIV patients will be treated and that
there'll be a 90% reduction in new HIV
cases by targeting specifically
high-risk populations and removing HCV
from these important prison walls and
this makes us confident that with the
next 10 15 maybe 20 or 25 years we'll be
able to control HCV infection as a
public health issue it may not be
exactly 2013 old countries but with the
drugs mishap and with the tools we have
this has become an achievable goal so on
this I would like to thank you very much
for your attention and I will be pleased
to take any question you may have thank
you very much
Thank You dr. Brodsky for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question in an answer
session I'd like to remind the audience
how to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing into the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A on the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can so let's get
started we have a wonderful audience
today our first question is given the
two-step process for diagnosis what can
I do to streamline current testing
practices identify your target waited
but I hope you can hear me so I I think
it's very important that you identify
your targets well and identify the best
people to screen the population I think
in many countries
Gero petitioners are very good the
target for screening they can be
informed they can be made aware that can
look for risk factors identify which
patients should be tested and generally
the patients are faithful to their
general practitioner and therefore will
come back to get the result of the
anti-hiv test and get confirmation if
the patient is anti G&T very positive
indeed this patient can be infected with
HIV are now and this is why we need
confirmation or this patient may not be
infected may be a cheater in a negative
and in that case the general
practitioner will be very helpful also
to explain that there is a mocker in
blood that the patient probably met the
virus at some point but this patient is
not infected is absolutely safe does not
need to be followed and can be referred
so I think really the general
practitioner is key as well as some
practitioners who are working in
specific areas where there are many
people such as people inject drugs
prisoners is a high prevalence of HIV
infection a high risk
of transmission I really believe
identifying which people will be running
the screening is extremely important
these people should not be trained to
treat patients it should really train to
be informed about hepatitis C and be
able to identify which patients make
them aware provide the right information
and then send you especially to will
start treatment after evaluation thank
you so much dr. Brodsky our next
question from our audience is why is
confirmation testing needed of so far
confirmation is needed because the
screening test is an anti HIV antibody
test which detects the presence of
antibodies but is not able to confirm
the presence of active replication so
people who do not have antibodies are
not infected but not all people who have
antibodies are infected and for that
reason it's necessary when somebody has
antigen antibodies to identify which
patients are HIV positive infected and
should be followed and sent to
especially for potential treatment this
is the reason why we still have to do it
in a detection and confirmation
procedure
much and I want to thank our audience we
have some wonderful questions coming in
our next question is my lab follows
local guidelines that haven't adopted
all the ESL recommendations yet if we
want to follow
ezal practices what can be done really
bounce well it really depends on the
level of freedom you have locally and
these old guidelines have been
established to be applicable everywhere
in the world and they're based only on
the science the expertise of the people
who wrote them and there is absolutely
no constraints related to a local
approval of any tests or any treatment
or any kind of reimbursement policy so
this make them universal and usable
everywhere but the limited there if one
practice which is recommended by years
old is not available in your country
there's nothing you can do and you
cannot use an essay which is not
approved or use a treatment is not
approved so I think you should do your
best to apply the easel guidelines in
your practice with the limitation of
what is available allowed and reimbursed
in your own country thank you dr.
Polanski we have some wonderful
questions coming in audience members
from around the world here's our next
question
if costs are similar and false-positive
Meg's are very low should each CV RNAi
be used for both screening and diagnosis
of HCV this would reduce barriers of
diagnosis but an avoid the confusion of
positive screen AIA with negative RNA I
think there's a two-part question there
I can repeat part of it if you need to
I didn't hear the question I lost you I
didn't see you so I see that you're
probably listening to me but I have
nothing to answer because I didn't get
the question sorry below let me repeat
that question for you an audience member
would like to know if costs were similar
and false positive negatives are very
low should each CV RNA be used for both
screening and diagnosis of HCV this
would reduce barriers to diagnosis and
avoid the confusion of positive screen
dia with negative RNA yes this is a
great question and the answer is
definitely yes if the cost was the same
if it was as easy to get cheaper any
testing as you do antigen antibody
testing definitely HCV RNA screening
would become standard of care and we
would have only one step which is
detection of active infection versus
nothing so the answer is yes but
unfortunately who do not yet have the
tools for that if one day we have a test
that is able to on the first testing
determine whether a patient is infected
with active replication it will replace
anti to the antibody screening
definitely yes very good question thank
you and here's another wonderful
question from our audience what are some
of the common practices for driving
public awareness of the need for HCV
testing can you share any examples that
worked well for you
well I can bring the French experience
which has been that the government has
decided in 2001 to having screen for HCV
and put together a national action plan
I think were the first country in the
world doing that and they decided clean
for people and form the population so
there were spots on TV and medias and
radios and Metro in Paris and everywhere
about heve and telling people if you're
at risk and they will this thing the
kind of risk that associated with a CB
go to see your general practitioner and
the second target was the GP themselves
were informed about the risk factors
paid to the inspection and were
encouraged to screen for HCV antibodies
and it worked very well because in three
years 2001 to 2004 were able to identify
60 to 65 percent of the patients were
thought to be infect in the country a
hundred thousand patients were missing
and and ten years later the number of
patients still missing 75 thousand and
it's possible that these patients in
fact do not exist so it's possible that
could be so good that in three years we
have been able to identify the vast
majority of our HIV infected patients I
see two risks two limitations and things
have to be taken into consideration with
a lot of care and it also can depend on
the on the culture of the country and
the habits in different areas of the
world
the first one is panic if you start a
big campaign for screening it's not
panic people that HIV is everywhere can
be transmitted etc and the second risk
is stigmatization and I think this it
could be taken care of very carefully
but with these to quotient' messages I
would say that it's possible to launch
campaigns and I know that other
countries are slightly different or
similar experiences and I've been very
efficient in screening the majority of
their patients
Thank You dr. Polanski and here's a
related question from you for up for MA
audience members can you comment on why
that HBV screening is important
prior to HCV treatment and two-part
question and what other testing may need
to be considered when managing patients
with hepatitis C another very good
question the reason why it's important
to screen for HPV as well is that in the
case of HPV HIV co-infection generally
HCV
inhibits hepatitis B virus and if you
treat HCV and cure HCV there is a risk
of reactivation of HPV infection and
this reactivation may have the serious
consequences on the liver such as alt
flares and and sometimes at future of
sub so many categories
however these cases are extremely rare
and most people are used to see
co-infected patients know how very well
how to monitor them and prevent it so
the two important markers are HBS
antigen which is a marker of chronic HPD
courage and patience or HBase Educare
ears should be considered as having HPV
co-infection together with HCV and in
these patients especially there is
detectable HCV replication it's
important to use granted therapy start
the nucleotide analog treatment or
nuclear side and a lot of treatment for
HPV before studying HD treatment the
other markers marker which has been
highly debated with the isolated
presence of anti-hbc antibodies which is
the vast majority of cases can be a
marker of fast soul infection poor can
be false positive and they have been
some reports of very rare cases of HPV
reactivation in patient's anti-hbc and
bodies present alone without HB s
antigen we got HPV DNA
and I think there is no consensus yet
but in most cases the recommendations
just monitored these patients follow
them closely could not start any granted
therapy with anti-treaty treatment thank
you so much dr. posny our next question
is in case of HCV
antibody positive would HCV RNA not be
detected should it be treated or not be
treated a patient who is HCV RNA
negative is not infected and so mud
should not be treated it should be
explained to this patient very clearly
that possibly the patient has been
inspected in the past but have been able
to cure the infection alone and does not
need treatment and I think these
patients must absolutely be reassured
and and this is really a very important
point being anti-qing antibody positive
that HCV RNA negative is being HCV non
infected and not taken thank you dr.
Brodsky here's a great question an
interesting one in Latin America the use
of Western blot how confident can firm
Ettore test is the first election that
is very expensive what is your opinion
about the use of this test well
disappoint you but I think something
like 20 years ago I I wrote several
papers showing that the Wesson block
confirmatory tests were useless to
confirm H an infection they can only
create discrepancies with the antibody
test but it's another type of antibody
test and therefore the only way to
confirm active infection is HT Verena
testing I understand this test is
expensive the contagion test is as we
discussed a potential alternative to a
cheater in a testing but there is no
other way to confirm active infection
and decide about the indication of
therapy but doing HCV RNA or contingent
testing and really the Western block
that we call the Reba assay should no
longer be used with stop using it 20
years ago in in my lab and in all over
Europe dr. Pulaski this next question is
a very interesting one when I think
everyone would like to know is complete
eradication of hepatitis C possible with
new technologies and therapies
[Music]
well it's a very good question that the
question is broader than that I guess
the question is can we eradicate an
infection that involved 70 million
people without a vaccine and we will
probably never have a vaccine we only
have what we have screening and
diagnostic tests on the one hand and
very efficient treatments on the other
hand with cure rates over 99% I think
with this we can control infection
meaning that in every country that has a
well-organized national action plan a
good screening strategy and excellent
linkage to care an acceptable cascade of
care and good treatment access in each
country like this we can make this
frequent disease or very rare disease it
doesn't mean that it will be eradicated
there'll be no more HCV infected people
in the country but there will be very
few and sometimes you will see one or
another coming from a different area a
transmission hiring these groups but
something very rare and that will be
controlled if after many years and I
think 2030 is probably a little bit
optimistic not optimistic from Western
Europe North America some Asian
countries we will achieve it but in
other countries it will take much more
time but I think at some point with the
very good drugs we have and if there is
a political willingness to tackle the
issue and will really do it it would be
possible to make these freakin disease a
rare disease
the term elimination eradication is I
think less realistic and more political
but sometimes it's good to speak about
unreachable achievements to make sure
that the politicians support us in the
in the fight and this is probably why
it's being used but I'm very optimistic
that it's a good drug we have will be
able to handle this and in might
concrete France we expect that within
the next five to seven years we will
have treated all the patients we have
identified and will be a it will be a
fast issue
Thank You dr. Pulaski and thank you for
our wonderful audience
today we have time for one last question
and this one comes from John Hopkins
School of Medicine
if HCV antigen detection is acceptable
to ezel at LL OQ 1000 IU milliliters why
must the HCV RNA not have elbow q of 15
Nowell this seems inconsistent it's a
very good question and I think I know
who had that question so I will answer
again because I already answered a
question another setting I think there
is a discrepancy in these or guidelines
and the reason why there is a
recommendation for high sensitivity for
HIV RNA testing is because in the past
guidelines especially the ones we were
using for taking the front and rod
ovarian or taken from rod of iron Philip
read here but separate here we need it
to be very sensitive down to 15-20 IU
per ml to detect the response on
treatment and terror treatment duration
to that response and I agree with the
person who had the question that there
is a discrepancy and that currently what
we need is to be able to detect
replication before therapy and for this
we don't need to be that sensitive and
if we accept that the coincidental guess
can do it with an equivalent to 500
3,000 IU per ml of HCV RNA the same high
lower limit of detection to be
acceptable to be a cheater and si and
the other utility of our testing is
after the end of treatment as year 12
and again the HCV RNA level in a patient
who relapses is generally high at this
time so I I completely agree that the 59
3 ml is roughly irrelevant for the news
we have of HCV nucleic acid testing and
I anticipate that there will be some
changes in the next verse
of ezel guideline that should be
published at the end of this year thank
you so much dr. Pulaski and thank you to
our audience members I'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor Abbott
today for making today's educational
webcast possible I want to remind our
audience members that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
until April 2018 you'll receive an email
from lab words alerting you when the
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to Ford that announcement to
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thanks again everyone
see you next time bye-bye